the result of the supreme court's
unanimous decision
is that ms bagan's appeal against the
leave to enter decision
is dismissed her application
for judicial review of the leave to
enter decision
is dismissed and her application for
judicial review
of syack's decision in her appeal
against the deprivation decision
is also dismissed
okay well that is the decision from the
uk supreme court ruling that
uh shimama begum who joined islamic
state in syria should not be allowed
to return to the uk to challenge that
decision to strip her of her citizenship
well let's
speak to our home affairs correspondent
mark white who's uh
joining me now um mark just uh drill us
down into that
decision that we've had there from the
supreme court
well these rulings are always quite
complex and
multi-uh pronged as this one was but the
upshot of it is that the home secretary
has won here it was a home secretary
that had gone
to the supreme court to challenge a
decision
that was made by the court last july
effectively that shamima began who is in
a
refugee camp in northern syria should be
allowed to
return to the uk there she could
effectively
fight a case against the decision that
was made by
a previous home secretary sajid javid
in 2019 to strip her over british
citizenship the argument being
that if she's in this refugee camp in
northern syria
without access to lawyers and being
denied that access she can't have
a fair and proper hearing she's not able
to mount that
uh and that was the thrust of the case
that was put before
the supreme court but supreme court
having weighed up all the facts
uh have found in favor of the home
secretary
who appealed against that court of
appeal decision
uh and so shamima begum has been denied
the right to return to the uk uh denied
the right to
appeal at the judicial review as well
against that deprivation order the
deprivation order
being that order first imposed by sajid
javid
to strip her off her british citizenship
clearly
the british government will be delighted
by this uh there was real concern
because
it's not just shamima begum here the
british government has stripped
150 people off their citizenship
mainly on security grounds in recent
years and there was a real concern
that should shema begin win and be
allowed to return this would be an
avenue of return
for dozens of others